for much of the 1990s actor and comedian
Martin Lawrence was one of the biggest
stars in Hollywood with a popular
long-running TV show a hit stand-up
album and a string of box-office hits
but Lawrence's ascent started to stall
toward the end of the decade and his
star power has been fading ever since so
where did he disappear to here's a look
at what Martin Lawrence has been up to
over the years early Fame martin
lawrence began his entertainment career
as a stand-up comedian but it wasn't
long before his act caught television
producers attention and he made his TV
debut on the series what's happening now
in 1992 lawrence was chosen to be the
first host of HBO's def Comedy Jam and
from there he found himself on the fast
track to fame not only did he land a
role in the eddie murphy comedy
boomerang but he also put his talents
front and center with his very own Fox
sitcom the aptly titled Martin the show
proved a major hit with audiences and
made it star a household name that was
enough to land him a role opposite Will
Smith in bad boys in 1995 and the rest
as they say is history
meltdown on the heels of major
box-office success lawrence kept himself
busy maybe a little too busy with his
first post bad boys brawl the actor set
out to reaffirm his leading man status
while proving he could write and direct
- but the pressure of carrying a film
almost entirely on his own may have
proved too much weeks into filming the
dark romantic comedy a thin line between
love and hate the actor had a meltdown
on the set and was hospitalized for
exhaustion rather than take time off
lawrence continued to book new work in
1996 he suffered another episode this
time stalking the streets of LA with a
pistol while shouting at passing cars
his second bout with exhaustion led to
another hospital stay this time Lawrence
got the message and stepped away from
the spotlight to heal personal drama
while his professional fortunes
skyrocketed Lawrence's private life grew
turbulent the comedian spent much of the
90s struggling with personal issues that
threatened to derail his career he
became engaged to Saved by the Bell
actress lark Voorhies in 1993 but the
relationship fell apart before year's
end he rebounded by marrying former Miss
Virginia
southall in 1995 and the pair had two
children together before divorcing in
1997 big-screen returned Lawrence eased
his way back into Hollywood's good
graces in 1999 with a couple of
successful comedies in life and blue
streak but he also found his way back
into the tabloids while prepping for his
next film Big Momma's House
Florence collapsed 12 jogging and 100
degree heat and ended up in a three day
coma I just picked the hottest day of
the summer next thing I know I sleep the
production was delayed while he
recovered but the time off didn't hurt
when the film finally arrived in
theaters in 2000 it raked in close to
180 million dollars worldwide just like
that Martin Lawrence was back on tap
box-office flops
unfortunately Lawrence followed his big
momma success with a string of genuine
misfires what's the worst that could
happen Black Knight and national
security all underperformed and in spite
of the solid box office returns for bad
boys two and a Big Momma's House sequel
he hasn't managed to write the ship for
good with his movies continuing to miss
the mark Lawrence tried to return to the
medium he once dominated television
unfortunately TV has proven a struggle
as well as Lawrence has seen networks
pass on his pilots and the one series
that did get picked up partners lasted
just 10 episodes before getting the acts
bad boys bust no roll seemed better
suited to get Lawrence back on track
than a return to his big screen breakout
as Marcus from bad boys now back up put
the gun down and give me a pack of
tropical fruit bubblicious some skills
after an extended period in development
limbo bad boys 3 aka bad boys for life
got some good news when writer director
Joe Carnahan came aboard it's really
they're working on the script again
close in as it all looks good but just
as things got cooking the piece is
holding the sequel together fell apart
Carnahan left the project and the studio
eventually pulled the film from its
release late like that
Lawrence's big screen comeback was over
before it even began semi comeback
lawrence decided to take his talents
back to the stand-up stage in 2016
martin lawrence do and
premiered on Showtime and marked his
first stand-up film in almost 15 years
sadly the Showtime special didn't put
Lawrence back in the spotlight doing
time arrived with little fanfare and was
met with critical and difference but as
with any other creative venture there's
also the possibility that he just needs
to get warmed up again it's always
possible that we'll be seeing a lot more
of Martin Lawrence in the future thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]